Oh what's up kiddos hey this is date
fails I'm Kate quickly
that was weird I know like because I
like I like when we're just all
bullshitting and then the show kind of
starts and I don't know it's starting
but I'm open if you will
yeah when I have to actually like
announce that we're on I get awkward I
do
Josh's wait I wasn't talking about your
intro like this wasn't an audio medium
that we're working in maybe turn back
that way like dude today is gonna be
really fun I think the most fun the most
amazing guest ever I not me actually
well you are you are incredible by the
way how great just gem look today Jen is
like supermodel stunning today you know
that's cuz that's a different person did
my beat no you're both are beautiful
don't do that
Josh told us before the show started
that we look like real no no let me
clarify I was doing an impression of my
mother who would say something like that
not me I don't even watch that show I'm
repeating verbatim yeah it's from I'm so
autistic I don't just keep it 100 I keep
it 200 that's by the way I didn't buy
the name it doesn't be the title of this
episode I'm so autistic I keep it 200
okay I got scared sorry don't listen
okay let me introduce you some people
know what's happening yeah it's probably
for the best so my guest today obviously
you all know my BFF hilarious comedian
actress host block Jennifer surgery
you're killing the brow Jen is hilarious
and gorgeous but go ahead Josh what do
you want to say no no
I was giving I was gonna do in love or
motherly compliments Oh Jenna's like
yeah adorable look at you I'm the worst
yes yes
so I'm Linda nice to meet you josh josh
Meyerowitz is my other guest today who
is a very funny comedian I love you I
love your work on all the podcast that
you're on your Twitter is fantastic is
the spirit animal of the roast battle
yes I think the wave word is spirit
animal no his Twitter handle is at
autistic Thunder and Josh is special
because he's like in the [ __ ] you
can't I should have brought you my
special helmet yeah helmet that I wear
just out in public to make sure I don't
hurt myself
my head against the wall so I don't
what's it called my pupils never mind
dislocate my dick my retinas there's not
a thing
yeah autistic people bang their heads
against wall that's why they put the
helmet on oh really
yeah that happened to me when I let a
porn star come in my eye yeah I recently
watched a porn come shot what that
happened and that lady got pissed oh
really he came and she was aiming for
the tenth color nice she's like you
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is severe it's
painful I do it now it sorry I can't
relate to your problems right now this
is a masturbating problem for me because
it's a clip I'm
you know and I by mistake listen I'm not
sharpshooter alright so josh is autistic
okay and Esper and this is your official
diagnosis the the the here's the thing
with that even though the name
Asperger's this excuse me Asperger's
this is it syndrome Asperger's syndrome
yeah yeah usually at this point they
don't use Asperger's anymore it's just
autism but because most people when it
comes to high-functioning autism don't
know that I just stick with Asperger's
that's not like I'm lying it is what it
is that's interesting that's really
interesting I didn't know that that's
what you had yes it's a as I've been
told a developmental disorder yeah yes
the major thing with autism general is
anxiety and per in my case perception
per not lack of perception but it's it I
there's like a social recognition you
you don't necessarily get yes tact is
off for me
exactly well sarcasm can be a little off
there I've loved comedians have taken to
be teachers to me and teach me social
cues that even my own actual school
teachers and sometimes even my parents
couldn't teach me that there were only
human these are perfect people to learn
sarcasm from here's my attempt oh you
guys are so beautiful today
you think I'm some people ask me would
you want to be cured if there was and
I'd say no because I'm scared without
autism might be a total [ __ ] no I'm
scared I'd be bad at comedy probably
love comedy I don't want to be bad at it
even though I already do suck you don't
you're so funny why do you think you'd
be bad at comedy if you if you weren't
Auto because then I'd be my twin brother
he's a bit like the rest of family he's
a good salesperson and he's a bit of I
love my brother but he's a bit of a
douche that's the best okay so I guess
but he's an [ __ ] so the best part
about Asperger's is you you like
physically cannot lie basically
ultimately can't here's what it is as an
autistic person I lack filtered I lack
tact I wanted to have you on it to try
to figure out if I'm actually on the
spectrum here's the here's the thing
every best thing I've heard is every
community's artistic are worse they just
haven't been diagnosed I'm one of the
few who's been legit I think that's true
I really do my nephew was autistic we
talked about this before actually my
nephew is autistic he's I think he's 10
now but my mom is always like to me
she's like Kate everything Conor does is
just you when you were his age she's
like are you sure you're not my mom is
like are you sure you're not autistic
who's sure I don't know that is the only
thing her parents have agreed on since I
got divorced was that she's likely
autistic this is true I unintentionally
a lesbian that was something else so out
there potential still hoping well I'm
just gonna go back to my imagination I
mean here's the thing is anxiety I have
really bad anxiety I have trouble with
intimacy and I don't I just don't know
what to do yeah well let's talk about I
want to tell this story that kind of
injure you right right because I think
when I describe you to people I'm always
like this is how like sweet and innocent
Josh's and how much he literally like
has no filter and okay well I just I
don't mean to be a pendant just to
describe the the whole I can't lie thing
I apologize for cutting you I I have I
lack filter I lack tact I've learned
things as I've grown up and as a human
being become more hopefully mature I
learned how much I hate lying and the
problems that can come from wine so
ultimately I decided because of all my
anxiety and everything I rather just be
a complete open book to people I had I'm
not
asked about anything I don't do anything
wrong any mistake I make I can tell
people and and it's completely honest
that I have no ill will I can admit if I
did something wrong and take
responsibility but for it
the only technically the only lies I can
tell are extremely common sensible white
lies but even then I don't even do those
yeah you really don't lie if you ask me
a question I will answer it one joke out
of 19 you really know that one just shut
up anyways continue what you're gonna
say before okay no but like you tell the
story this is the story of how I was
like oh my god this guy is so amazing so
Josh and I used to do open mic together
yes and there was this open mic one day
that we did and then I think we went
across the street to a comic book store
afterwards about down around yeah
wandering around the comic book store
and Josh do you remember what you said
to me wait are you referring to when I
asked you as friends if we got a second
mic not know what was that the comic
books
I remember sitting my side to you at the
open mic so josh is like I thought we
were at the comic book store but
whatever we're hanging out and josh is
like Kate I have a question for you but
I don't know if I can ask it because I
don't want to offend you I said hey you
can ask me anything Josh what is it and
he was like well I was just wondering
sometimes you know just like as friends
if maybe we could have sex no it's a
weird question Josh I have told the
story like even when I told Jen I was
like it was the sweetest it was like the
nicest way anyone who's ever been like
because I also say don't worry if you
say no you're my friend no matter what
say that yeah he did say that's
important to me yeah don't worry if you
say no and then I was like sure no I was
like we probably shouldn't just because
we're friends and it would be weird if
we if we did I think but like us I'd be
terrible at it but so at the time were
you a virgin yeah because yeah because I
lost my virginity four years ago I'm 32
years old right now you what guys lie on
me the top of that story or count that
story I mean we'll get to it Morgan my
bad no we do want to hear about it I
don't know what so there so Kate very
graciously it was like I don't think
this is a good idea because like you
just comics shouldn't whatever with
comics you know but then there was a
follow up right yeah I think you said
something
I totally get if I did that I'm not I'm
not surprised so I want to learn I don't
like a lady lady you could teach me how
to make some dick look because that
sounds like I'm slut-shaming I'm not
like 15 to 17 people I want it out there
because people think that I [ __ ]
everyone and I only [ __ ] the few and the
proud but this goes to the point I'll
try to make your experience you know
what you're doing so I figure I have
something to learn from you at that time
yeah I know I ask the questions because
you were into me or wanted a bang no I
was also that he wanted the reps man hey
I'm just like I get confused went of an
open mic but fervid oh okay so you're
still my friend
and then after that you always would
like hit me up for girl advice which I
thought was the coolest I was you're my
friend and I respect you wait I've had a
handful of female friends who have asked
this and I would hope they really made a
mistake when it comes to it being
disrespect has anyone been like sure no
but but it's come back to something I
recently acquired myself a friend with
benefits
don't stop apologizing I can't I know I
know
okay so before we get to you losing your
virginity can you tell us about like how
did you even start dating cuz you lived
with your parents that's the thing okay
so I live my parents until about 31 and
a half years old yeah III and here's the
thing I never mind living my parents I
paid room and board I was I love my
parents as much anxiety they instilled
me with that wasn't already there to
begin with granted but uh but yeah I
would come into Hollywood because I
wanted to perfect myself and hopefully
become eventually become a road comic
and commies the best thing I ever
happened for me because I never had a
social life or really any friends before
stand-up and now I found everyone and
they accept me and bring me in like I'm
one of theirs I had never experienced
that before outside my immediate family
of course but this granted also opened
up dating to me and I wanted it and I
particularly asked out female comedians
because I relate to them more than I do
women outside the comedy they're like me
I want to deal with someone who's [ __ ]
up like me thank you
the original idea was gonna ask you out
on a date but I feel like you have like
extreme you're a very beautiful woman so
I feel like you have very high standards
and I do not match those standards no
she doesn't but thank you Josh and also
just so you know you are like a way
better quality of man than 99% of the
guys that I did would you like to date
wise try me out you can say I don't know
it just felt right I don't date comics
that's a doll you said you're a comic
listen you don't need this goon around
you all right you're not a good no I
adore you I do have a neckbeard first
date I
remember I think it was this she wasn't
a comic but she worked for the Hollywood
improv as like a door person and and we
went on it on one day and she's like I
was like I just like he has a friend I'm
like that's cool and then I dated a
couple of female comics I don't know if
I should name because I did there's only
one I can name okay is Tiffany Haddish
what once yeah whoa just one date yeah
yeah she's awesome but she's the best
yeah yeah yeah yeah we tried to go for a
second date but it never fell it fell
through every time so we just you know
she's a busy lady I'm not gonna bother
yeah it's all good plus a lot of comics
were like you shouldn't date here she's
she's a wife she's wild that's most
girls that are we got bang Tiffany my
friend Melanie baldanado who's a
wonderful comic she's like if she
thought you you would have no control
you it would be the wildest ride you've
ever been on wild it in a roller coaster
TIFF is awesome I love her cause she
just like flirts without everybody and I
just love that she's like an equal
opportunity of like she will flirt with
you no matter who you are she taught me
how the dawn dates better just by that
one day we we want we we like sparked at
the Comedy Store we walked all the way
to like a mile and a half or two to the
this good ramen place urban ramen plug
plug plug great and it's a place I go to
all the time I don't you [ __ ] sponsor
I know I wish oh my god Josh getting
spider I can't even get a boat I'm
sponsored by mediocrity anyways I I'm
not sponsored I just really liked that
place anyways
come on the urban ramen sponsor me on
one date with Tim and when we walked
back to the House of Blues one now still
around we watched some rapper and then
it was cool and then we took a kiss no I
want point I tried because I didn't know
better and she's like not and it's like
okay I'm not forceful I'm I'm I don't I
III don't even remember if I really
tried to kiss or I don't know what it
was maybe I tried to put was your first
kiss like yeah
yes how old were you I was I want to say
sixteen no wait wait wait wait yes
sixteen or seventeen I went to this
continuation High School where I was the
only liked person with this continuation
of high schools for delinquents like bad
girls I went to that high
this was actually I I was the only
person there that wasn't delinquent I
was me obviously and and and and I had
trouble studying that's why I say I'm
the dumbest autistic person you ever met
anyways that's I thought it's a funny
line anyways funny
thank you much love you uh I hope I'm
not being conceited or selfish alright
anyways so I went to us continuation
high school and they had a party I think
yeah like a party once at someplace
house in a rich neighborhood and we were
all in jacuzzi and there was these this
these two girls and me and there it was
true for dare and I got like triple kiss
just like a dare kiss no put your mouth
on there round yes and I felt their
tongues that was my first kiss the guy
didn't know what he was doing so he
stuck his tongue outside his mouth so
our tongues were like out here just like
yeah yeah yeah thank you I am starting
to think so that was your first kiss
because then I had a technically had a
girlfriend in my very early choice 19 20
years old we dry hump that's the closest
anyone we know 19 did you know you
weren't having sex or no no I definitely
knew I trust me I wanted to get in that
[ __ ] like she would I had a feeling that
at the end of the relationship that this
probably was there was definitely for
the best because although I still like
who wondered it she did well here's what
I started it but she under the eyes
asked her we went to some indie comic
convention at UCLA which is where I met
her I'm us I wasn't a student there but
I went to a free UCLA Japanese animation
Club which she was a student at UCLA and
that's how we met and she was a weirdo
like me and she's cute asian girl of
course a nerdy G like me totally into we
love the Asians many men tell me about
it so we were together for about a year
like my favorite memory was the night we
we dry-humped on Halloween I was just
like [ __ ] given Kenny's kids we're got
we were in my room I was just like I'm
gonna get some candy in her pants oh
wait did you ever get to go down on her
and then if she didn't like it so much I
sort of lick above her panic like on her
panties but like on where to cut is her
vagina was and she's like nah don't do
that over the panties I've done that to
a dude before so don't feel bad I just
go just stop neither of us knew what the
[ __ ] we were doing like like she was she
was so weird and one time we were in the
back of my friends cars we were giving
her a ride home and I was like fingering
her for panties she said out loud is
this dry humping I'm like like she might
be cool [ __ ] so so we broke up we broke
up was we went to his indeed well she
sort of seemed disconcerted I said to
her do you want a break do you look do
you want to break up with me and she's
like yes and I took it amicably until
the for the two year like once a year
for the next two years I would just I
would call her just about video games
because because this always happened
that day and I still like so what did
you mean by homely I mean he called you
homely and she was homely not to it so
she she was beautiful than me that's
what counts
what she called you homely or you call
her I was pretty damn homely back then
especially
call me home called you home yeah [ __ ]
she's nice she's that my mother was like
and it makes sense even though it might
not be true she's like didn't you know
she was Asperger's like you that's why
you got along why she makes sense
honesty for any relationship like it
kind of smells down here he's like
that's cool you're homeless body homely
or not it was mostly my fault
especially that what the night we
dry-humped I was talking about I feel
like after you years from now after you
graduate college and I and I'd find a
stable enough income let's get married
like I basically proposed to her in
advert not that we did I didn't because
there was no yes or no or anything but
like I was rushing it without even
realizing it it's my fault I take
responsibility for the break-up okay so
fast-forward
wait did you okay 28 years old when I
had sex yes what happened was another
comedian who I can't say no you can't
please don't know but I've been sworn to
secrecy and we won't ask you because you
can't lie to us so you just okay keep
talking this guy the guy who got you
that should have said guy it's okay I
know trust me for a lot of time I was
like let's get a pool and get a money
pull together and get him a prostitute
so I used this guy I hung out with a lot
still kind of do
we're friends nonetheless he he's like
hey listen I gather this massage parlor
quote-unquote all the time there's this
girl Sofia there she's so hot only 150
bucks and you could [ __ ] her and and and
and he this happened constantly and I'm
like nah man because he was a thing I
better for us I am a romantic I wanted
to in my mind these words urn the vagina
I wanted
the farm love truly mutual sex I'm not
saying the prostitutes not mutual but
you're paying for that mutual yeah for
that god it's not mutual not mutual not
that's the wrong word what's it called
what not consensual there we go
it's consensual right it's real sex but
it's not real okay continue well so so
he finally convinced me and I went I
they kept me outside in the huts well I
think it was June Sun for like three
hours because they thought I'm a
clean-cut white boy so I must be a cop
like they didn't say that to me but I
think I got your like by the time you
like no one's gonna wanna have sex with
me I wasn't thinking about that I was
plus I cleaned I cleaned up real well so
I thank God yeah they do in the hot Sun
for three hours and then and then they
kept me once I was inside in the the
room waiting another hour because she
was finishing up like man he really
wants this Wow that too I was finishing
up with another she was finishing up
with another customer yeah did that
bother you at all no I was trying to
take as always not to toot my own horn
take consideration during sex I asked
her hey I hope I'm not taking too long
no girl will ever complain about that
why am I taking too long
you can't take too long yes you can no I
disagree well you'll hear my stories and
yo yo you'll judge from there so but
yeah after that she's like massaging me
and he's like touch your leg and say I
want everything wait oh yeah I was like
he's he in the room - I miss - I do not
cook wait did you pay for this or that
comic paint oh that's a comic gave me
150 and I paid because wait wait hold on
because I don't want to spend disability
money on groceries yeah another oh this
is my first time it's all good I pay
people for sex - I just pay with like
burritos and jewelry yeah yeah I I feel
like any guy all you have to say is I
will have sex with you and they'd be
like you wouldn't think that would be
that easy
hey it's finding out that that's quite
it turns out there are some guys that
just don't care man what do Sh bags in
great you're being amazing Mutchler the
prostitute was you losing your birthday
yeah it was here's the thing it took a
very hard time for me to come because I
masturbate oh this will come back into
the story yeah this is how much I
masturbate to the point that I run a
seed like I run out of juice so some
common problems so so I didn't know I
was gonna do this that day at all so
she's at the end she's checking me off
so hard she's whipping out skin and
Holmes
well she but here's the thing I have a
small dick so she any kind of Luke from
the condom or that she put on it was
just it would be it would be hard to
because her hands are just slipping off
cuz like it's it's ridiculous like like
I can't win but so so I eventually
managed to come I did ask her I was
trying our budget things during sex like
can I kiss you can I come on your tits
no she said what the kiss just pecked me
on the lips are on the cheek kissing I
wasn't come on the tits that's a that's
a deal-breaker I
she never said that's extra extra money
so
I'm a man of high spots where the [ __ ]
goes I didn't know she got out of like
tissues or like a listen that's what I
use anyways that's all you got it out of
the way that's great how was it great I
felt so good like when I walked to my
friend's car because same friend who
gave me 100 picked 150 pick me up and
I'm like am i glowing am I is I because
my pregnant fellow while rolling the
glowing thing I I thought was a real
thing from Mallrats when after Joey
Lauren Adams and and and Jason Leigh's
character have sex he's like dude you're
glowing I'm like I know right now you're
gonna have superpowers no I'm not going
like telling just like you're here and
like you're your mojo or no you are
though actually but here's the thing
that first time was so great because it
made me feel so confident not
overconfident but so confident I felt
less autistic oh I say on stage it's
like I got cared of my autism for a
moment so that's cures autism yes take
notes Jenny McCarthy I think that you
know that you actually there is a
chemical thing that happens after you
have sex where they say that you're like
emitting right after you orgasm you're
emitting like this pheromone that makes
you more attractive to the other sex
the best was open and afterward and I
was telling everyone because everyone I
know we're not gonna be like guys I've
an announcement to make
yes absolutely oh my god because
everyone everyone knows my in the that
knows me knows my story knows how bad I
am with women by the way just explain
why I'm so bad woman I'm mr. nice guy
not that I feel like oh I'm nice you
should date me you should have sex with
me no no man or a woman owes me anything
period in fact all this long time taking
they even get laid gave me more of a
consideration and appreciation of women
oh maybe I should State job
so you want me you're the perfect guy
III hope to that one day someone I'm
mentally and physically attracted to
finds me the same way they will we all
want that yeah everybody wants that no
matter who you are Josh trust me when I
tell you it's hard to find for anyone
Yeah right I just want people know that
I know why I'm bad with women I I don't
I don't
I best to only change so much because
I'm only human then there are things I
can't change at all
yeah to work on you can always strive to
be a better human being but at some
basic level we are all who we are I know
we're about we're just certain
characteristics certain traits like
stress or personality I'd like to think
I'm the good kind of people pleaser and
dad I don't want people take advantage
of me I don't do it to make them just
happy I do it because it makes me happy
I'm a nice guy cuz I like the feeling of
being nice because I want people it's
not just a reputational thing I love
people and I do fight of everyone but I
can't stay so so now you alright
flash-forward what's what's the
situation now that we talked about the
other night and then you said there's an
update yes
so a as of a month ago and this is big
news for me as of a month ago I have
acquired myself a friend with benefits
what happened so I got to I got to Earls
house to watch the game yeah I got to
his house to watch the fight and Josh
was there and here Jen guess what and I
said what he goes just had sex yes I
just you guys I had sex for real he goes
first Oh a prostitute
this is something I've already got a
high five yeah I
yeah like it's not me bragging even
though everyone's like it was totally
odd I know I don't like arrogance in
myself so but that's me you're allowed
to brag every guy brags when he's like
getting good you like when a guy is like
hooking up with like a hot chick he's
like yeah they are Brad I'm just so
happy I brag anytime I go lame I tell
the cashier at Ralph's like hey got
[ __ ] today never happened yeah that is
horrifying the surprising anyway so so
what happened was so I'm part of roast
battle plug plug plug at the Comedy
Store and I met this lady who was
watching it she came for a couple weeks
and she was really nice to me and she's
after one of my said she's like hey I'd
love to help you around like that'd be
great now we got together with no
intention of [ __ ] at all okay this is
entirely inadvertent situation we were
like we got dinner split checks nothing
romantic nor is after [ __ ] will we
ever be romantic it's purely friends
with benefits Wow so we yeah we got
checked we're talking together she's she
I'm telling her about myself because so
she can help right for me and and one of
the things I tell her what's a club when
you bring back something old in the
comedy set a callback callback I tell
her about have a handful of female
friends who have asked as friends if we
could have sex well we're in my room
because I'm not trying to bed her I
think I just I'm it's a comfortable
place we're staying in my room talking
like where I sleep over like sitting
indian-style just like so and so I tell
her this and she's like I'll have sex
with you now now this is a woman now now
to describe her she's she's like a porno
version of Samantha B from you know full
frontal yes okay I like Samantha be so
like and anything porno version of
anyone is usually pretty good yeah yeah
like she's really need to see them in
soft-focus but they're usually she's
she's been she's a sure she's sort of
like if she's all that situation with
with her hair so soft focus
oh yeah like like glasses on hair like
ponytail or just normal
trips downstairs perfect yeah she you'd
think oh she's a library lady but but
but she takes off all her clothes and
their glasses she's like and throws her
hair too
sigh I'm like oh my god so anyway she
says I'll have sex you now I am not only
instantly say what I'm pumped you know
said more than in more than one ways
like my dick is like just like when the
prostitute like it is like super like
like what's happens yeah yeah and first
I was hesitant because she said don't
worry I asked her because and this is
the same thing we're prostitute I was
the first one asked do you have a condom
and luckily what the process is bond she
before I could even completely says
she's like and she walked out came back
with a condom anyways in her case she
was like no I don't have a condom but I
trust me I don't have any STDs and I I
can't get pregnant at all so it's
usually the guy is the one who's like I
don't but like I don't have I didn't
have any condoms and and I almost said
no but you know it I what were you
worried about catching no I didn't want
to make her pregnant I don't see Dee I'm
cool at comitia but babies [ __ ] that
committee I was like I was I was hoping
she didn't have any STDs either and she
didn't say two hours past I was fine no
burning no is that the amount of time it
takes they say 72 hours I was told I'm
merely repeating the Taoist or so okay
so I just I yeah I'm like [ __ ] it yeah
let's do this
and she ate her out she's telling me
what to do do you calming her let me get
to that oh hey you can't do that that
that's the thing okay so so by the way
fun thing after the prostitute all the
commuters were like oh you know it was
your virginity you were wearing a condom
you didn't but you really losing your
virginity is bad for not wearing a
condom and busting inside there no
that's not true I know I know that's
just stupid
oh I can't even anyways so so so she's
teaching she's giving me little tips how
to either out which is great this is my
first time ever doing that period for
real nice kissing her she's like
teaching me how to be less aggressive
because I don't know better I don't like
like
but I'm like I like she's teaching me
how to soften my lips kinda and I'm and
now I have to admit with the prostitute
I wasn't nervous but with this
especially for cuz he might actually
like this girl well this isn't the
breaker that she's Asperger's as well
that's why it was a good idea but she
has a fifteen-year-old Asperger's
daughter
oh so that's I don't know yeah yeah and
and and I honestly like I don't want to
have kids even if I don't know if I ever
want to have kids or even get married I
don't I don't want one little thing at a
time but yeah I don't look at this lady
in any romantic way not that I don't not
fond for her that I wouldn't have sex
with her if I wasn't fond with her and
not using her for sex this just was but
kind of become like I still want to have
her help me right so anyways so oh she's
teaching me how to kiss and I put it
inside and it's just it they all right
sex without a condom feels amazing it
just feels like you're in something like
warm and it's pulling at you and like
it's like pulling all sides from your
dick and like it's just and and like so
you can ask see you can get details like
this yeah from Josh when a normal guy be
like it feels like sex with Josh is like
let me let me give you the gist
like I wash you write romance novels but
you don't worry cuz I I have a theory
that when you [ __ ] without a condom is
when you catch feelings see I didn't
feel I was just so into here's the thing
now now this is practically hearsay to
me because I don't think she was lying
to me and not just because she she's
possibly autistic like me as well but
I'll just I we [ __ ] five times that
night I and she said I am five times
that's the thing I it's 32 years of
constant masturbation
I and it was also I admit I was also
nervous I even though I'm a sheep first
of all she said and I'm that she said
this I I if she's lying to me
[ __ ] but if she's not awesome she said I
made her [ __ ] all five times more
originally just gonna [ __ ] four times
but she's at we were just laying in my
bed together and I'm like kinda wanna
and she's like okay like and we [ __ ]
like I when I know when the late when I
know how to be intimately aggressive in
a sense like not bad aggressive but like
when I like when I as an autistic person
because you take the initiative that's
the easier learning social cues this is
good
exactly learning social cues through sex
with strangers she's a new friend I
could use a new friend okay okay yeah so
she and she says about my penis
I'm not big or small I'm just normal
which is cool I once again just like you
ever measured it no because I don't know
what to do
I really don't put a ruler no no I know
but I don't I'm I'm I'm I'm a
perfectionist and I in a way I don't
understand how they use a ruler in a
weird way so so like I need maybe I'll
ask her I don't I'm she's like okay
before we have sex because that gets in
the way of everything that's right first
and then we'll [ __ ] want to measure
it now I'm kidding this other podcast I
did and you are measuring dicks no Josh
Byerly I you know which Slayton yeah
he's a good guy yeah and he's like I was
talking about my piece of smaller than
flaccid it looks like an acorn resting
on a frog's throat he's like show me I'm
like okay I'm an open book
I'm an open book so I showed them my
dick like I'm not I'm not
yeah I was kidding I don't wanna see
your dick right no I'm not I'm just
saying that has happened can you imagine
if a girl had that and guys were like
always like sure can you imagine
we have actually a caller Josh take a
call real quick do it I'm not coming off
like a badger coming off a horrible
pervert and I love it I'd like to think
of the good kind you like the good
pervert you like the angel pervert
respectful we have a caller who is on
the line oh he hung up cuz listen we
were almost out of time should i want to
hear your update all right so the update
is I never even this goes with a
completion of the first time I had sex
with this lady I couldn't come the whole
time not just I I don't know if it was
just because of the nervous I jerk off
so 30 years of constant jerking off porn
has desensitized me like she she tries
sometimes really jerk me off hard she's
kinky she liked to watch me masturbate
she's like yeah blow load on my tits and
I did the second time I fine the second
time we got together I got the blonde
tits she has nice like semi fakes like
she has natural tits that after she had
her kid like really filled out so she
filled them out but I know I know that's
how I know I know my own smelly what's
your question to question of course I'll
keep it short and sweet okay I was
having sex with this dish injure and
near the end of it okay
she tried to you know toss my salad okay
and she felt like drove my legs back she
tried to get the extra aggresses okay
and I was taken back for two reason one
with this tiny ninety pound ginger was
being incredibly aggressive when you
like a wrestler and two
for sure only dude said she talked to
salad the four major they want to do
this without even asking me permission I
mean what's the question
wait she didn't ask permission for the
coup de Gras just to push her away and
you know I didn't want to kiss her
afterwards I mean how many would
thinking how many doing so she probably
like just stay away from the groceries
and everything else is cool yeah I feel
like like anything especially if you're
in a no relationship well lady you work
into it you take it slow you don't just
I listen I barely know about sex I like
this josh is an expert now he's like
banging this girl here's what I think
wait I just think it is a little weird
that she did it after you came like I
find that to be a little odd like you
guys were basically cuz usually for me
like when the guy comes that's the end
like it doesn't there's nothing else
happening yet I was like an after the
credits scene Sam Jackson comes out in
tosses your salad I guess like some guys
are super into it so like I've always
heard that you know you should kind of
like go down there with your tongue and
see how they react and then if they're
like cool then you know they're into
like some but stuff and if they pull
away then you know they're not you don't
have to even like ask that's what that's
what I've heard and that's what I do I
don't know if I do it to a lady what I
don't know I mean oh yeah I'm saying I
would work into it like I said before I
I don't know if I don't know but I'm
down for if it happens to me
granted I'm not very comfortable with
like either I want
myself in the shower and I wipe my ass
with them because that's just
cleanliness
I actually do the same thing to my ass
if I'm gonna hook up in case the guy
goes there I know from the impact I mean
she was like emotional how hard did you
hit her did you leave marks like
long-term old well I mean lasted a few
days you know but I mean at the time you
know you could see masturbate a lot of
Japanese animated porn so I don't here's
the thing here's why I bring it up
there's a always a cliche in Japanese
anime porn where the girls being [ __ ]
so good oh I'm crying cuz you're [ __ ]
me so good like if that was a real thing
I might not be against it but at the
same time like if she's crying I think
something's wrong I'm scared
yeah social I don't think you make girls
cry and I will say that like I like guys
that are really rough in bed and and I'm
all down for some slapping but I also
have hooked up with a guy that can be a
little too rough and so I just think
there's a fine like if she's there's a
fine line and jump into K and say here's
my thing I mean I'm all for a good beat
down if I'm at the pool two days later
and every dude at the pools I go girl
because I got handprints on both ass
cheeks that's a problem I feel like I'm
the remote on a massage chair
I'm as rough as you want me to be I say
if you think you're hitting or too hard
maybe just pull back a notch that's all
so if she likes it you'll know yeah I
did that the second time we got together
me and my friend were benefits like I
like she likes dirty talk and I so
that's been everyone guys so spank you I
just add know where I'm like he wanted
to because she's like yes and I spanking
her like here's the thing I didn't get
outside of masturbating the porn and
getting the come on her I still couldn't
come inside her it wasn't her though I'm
I don't know if it's just nervousness or
okay like like here's the thing though
like especially once when she comes to I
just like she likes it too when I'm just
like hitting into her even though she's
already come she says oh yeah because
she's a girl she'll come again yeah yeah
but it's just that it feels like it is
slippery and mushy and it feels like
because when she caught me also rather
than hot and just I'm sorry I'm in shock
over you know you're great I love it
it's getting off listen I we need to end
this before I come hopefully I haven't
done that on camera
and I'd like to call oh my god I hope to
come sigh lady one day you will Josh you
have a time you're learning use the
secret in your [ __ ] I like that thank
you for your phone call sir thanks man
take it easy we have to go I hope I
haven't been too gross or perverted not
at all hilarious I would love to have
you back again I have much to say i I
can see that
next time way more calls that was
hilarious please I'm the Howard Stern
rule of things you ask me anything
answered I mean in this case he asks
anything but but I will answer any
question like if I have a secret I say
oh that's a secret yeah I like like I'm
even honest about that like I you will
not hear a lie from me guys you need to
follow Josh at autistic thunder on
everything because amazing you can ask
me questions on there to answer anything
it's not just know people are willing to
do it I'll do it Josh you're amazing
thank you for being here for having me
on course do you want to plug anything
yes two things uh first and foremost
roast battle every Tuesday night at the
world-famous Comedy Store at 10:30 and
it is now coming to Comedy Central
ceilings I hope you enjoyed the Montreal
Comedy Festival shows and then I have my
own podcast it's a podcast about eating
and reviewing pizza with the sub subject
being Pro Wrestling the title of
literally Josh low Simpson Pizza records
also Pro Wrestling so you can hit me
clean buttholes doesn't so so hit me up
on Twitter for that Josh loves him wait
it's jl h SP @ jl h SP or Josh loves him
some pizza at Lipson calm for the
foulest we're trying iTunes but no no
success over Josh you're great Thank You
Jesse loving me you're great
okay yeah I just got asked to do some
really cool roast stuff yeah we'll see
how that goes I'm really excited X now
while I'm sitting here so I get to go
write some bad 3070 battlin nope no
shits Topsy and so roast off and if you
guys want a pet please come and get them
from my apartment because I'd like my
life back it's like the you monster
dog you like adopt this one right here
it's available this is um Steve Buscemi
whoa we call it voo and we call him boo
first I was gonna take him but then he
everyone amused him by this whole
situation yeah he's not in Lhasa niblets
guys follow me @kq funny follow Janet
Jennifer stir jurat autistic thunder
dude you